good morning everyone we start with this
Paul Manafort is going to prison amid a
barrage of criticism from people who say
president Trump's former campaign
chairman got off easy
a judge sentenced mana for 247 months
yesterday for for fraud and tax evasion
not related to the Trump campaign that
sentence is far less than the nearly 25
years prosecutors wanted mana for told
the judge quote to say I am humiliated
and shamed would be a gross
understatement Paula Reid covered
yesterday's hearing and she is at the
White House Paul it's fair to say this
was a surprising sentence this was a
shocking sentence bianna and this was
also a surprise because this is the
first time we heard from metaphor but he
did not express any remorse for what he
had done and the judge commented he said
I'm surprised not to hear you express
more regret or apologize but then of
course the judge had a surprise of his
own when he shocked this packed
courtroom by sentencing man afford to
just a fraction of what was recommended
he accepts responsibility for his
conduct Paul Manafort sitting in a
wheelchair because of complications from
gout said before his sentencing that he
feels pain and shame adding my life
professionally and financially is in
shambles
after a short recess it was Judge ts
Alice's turn to speak he called the
charges undeniably serious and said
Manafort made choices to engage in
criminal conduct but Judge Alice then
seemed to give the former Trump campaign
chairman the benefit of the doubt saying
that mana fort lived an otherwise
blameless life and he has engaged in
lots of good things Ellis called the
recommended sentence of 19 to 24 years
behind bars excessive and handed men
afford a term of nearly four years Manta
Ford had agreed to cooperate with a
Muller investigation last September but
the agreement fell apart
prosecutors say mana fort lied
repeatedly to the special counsels
office the FBI and a grand jury
you know Paul Manafort worked for me for
a very short period of time the
president has sought to distance himself
from his former campaign chairman but
mana fort was a public part of his
campaign even defending then candidate
Trump against charges of Russian
collusion on
yes this morning so to be clear mr.
Trump has no financial relationships
with any Russian oligarchs that's what
he said that's what I said that's
obviously what the our position is while
they stopped working together in August
of 2016
mana forts strategy has always been to
angle for a presidential pardon one of
the reasons I respect for man afford so
much is he went through that trial you
know they make up stories people make up
stories this whole thing about flipping
they call it next week mana fort will be
sentenced here in Washington in a
separate case by a judge who has been
much tougher on him and that judge will
need to decide whether or not he can
serve both sentences at the same time
John Paula thank you